>> Sean: THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
IS MAKING ITS WAY NORTH RIGHT TO
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, AND FOX
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        T
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        M
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        I
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        L
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        H
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        E
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        N
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        M
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        K
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        N
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        G
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        H
NATION'S AUTONOMY LARON        S
WAY TO LOS ANGELES.
>> CAN ASK YOU A QUESTION REALLY
QUICK?
ARE YOU AWARE OF WHAT'S GOING ON
AT OUR BORDER WITH MIGRANT
CARAVANS COMING IN AND THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL AMERICA?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S A NICE PLACE TO
BE AT.
>> IF I WAS OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES I WOULD DO
EVERYTHING I COULD TO GET HERE.
>> IF YOU DON'T STOP THIS
CARAVAN, ANOTHER ONE WILL BE
BUILT.
>> I DON'T THINK THE ENTIRE
CARAVAN IS FILLED WITH BAD
PEOPLE AND HOMBRES.
BUT WE CAN'T HAVE A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDER.
>> THERE SHOULD BE SOME AMNESTY
GRANTED TO THEM BECAUSE OF THE
TRAVESTIES OCCURRING IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> WE TAKE CARE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FIRST AND FOREMOST BEFORE
WE DEAL WITH ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COUNTRIES.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE A WALL ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
COMING IN?
>> THERE SHOULD NO BE IN A WL
>> THERE SHOULD NO BE IN A W.
>> A WALL, BERIA IS THE
STUPIDEST THING.
LOOK AT THE WALL OF CHINA.
>> THERE SHOULD BE NO WALL IN
OUR PLANET.
IT'S JUST WRONG.
IMAGINE EVERY COUNTRY HAD OUR
WALL, HOW WOULD WE EVER MOVE
AROUND?
>> DOESN'T MAKE YOU NERVOUS
ABOUT WHO WOULD BE COMING OVER
HERE SINCE WE DON'T KNOW WHO
THESE PEOPLE ARE?
>> KNOW BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHO
MOST OF THE PEOPLE ALREADY ARE
THAT ARE HERE.
>> GOD BLESS AMERICA, EVERYONE
OF YOU IS WELCOME HERE.
I LOVE YOU, PEACE OUT.
>> Sean: TOMMY WILL BE PART OF
THE ALL NEW FOX NATION FIRST
LOOK WHICH AIRS SUNDAY NIGHT AT
8:00 P.M. RIGHT HERE ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
ACTUALLY, I MIGHT EVEN BE ON FOX
NATION, AND IF I DO, IT'S GOING